من جهته شدد المدير العام لمنظمه الصحه
العالميه تدروس ادانوم جبريسوس على ان
سكان القطاع يموتون من الجوع بسبب القيود
المفروضه على المساعدات الانسانيه واضاف
ان خطر المجاعه مرتفع ويتزايد كل يوم مع
استمرار القتال وتقييد وصول المعونات
استمرار القتال وتقييد وصول المساعدات
الانسانيه لا تزال منظمه الصحه العالميه
تواجه تحديات كبيره في دعم النظام الصحي
والعاملين فيه وحتى الان هناك اكثر من 100
الف من سكان غزه اما قتلى او جرحى او
مفقودون ويفترض انهم ماتوا وقد واجهت
منظمه الصحه العالميه صعوبه كبيره حتى في
الوصول الى المستشفيات في جنوب غزه وخلال
مهمه الامم المتحده يوم الاثنين سلمت
المنظمه امدادات طبيه الى مجمع ناصر طبي
بينما منعت بعثات اخرى من توصيل الوقود
والغذاء ان اتهام السفير الاسرائيلي لنا
بالتواطؤ هو في الحقيقه امر غير مسؤول
لانه قد يعرض موظفين للخطر لكن اود ان
اؤكد للسفير انه لا يوجد اي تواطؤ ومنظمه
الصحه العالميه تضحد اي اتهام نحن محايدون
ونقوم
بعملنا